hello everybody my name is markiplier
I'm here with Bob and Wade say hi hey
everybody
hi everybody hi everybody and we are
here in the mines of moria emerald mines
I think that's copyrighted oh it's not
what that looks like
the mines of Maury the mauryas
fidelity's my long time ago and okay the
objective here is um see this emerald
block we have to take these emerald
blocks cuz this place have been infested
and because I won the last one I am
totally unarmored and these two deuces
right here have to protect me until we
get it out and we need a minimum of ten
mocks in order to win this is a
cooperative game so are you guys ready
we're ready to rumble I guess yeah
anyway before that what are you drinking
there Bob I can't show it to the camera
cuz I can't hold it sideways but ah
there it is Oh make a little traction
okey-dokey wait what are you doing in
there
root beer and vodka I'm drinking Dr
Pepper and cap Morgan's again and we
have been drinking for a while cos Bob
was late yep bob was very an hour late
so we're ready getting drunk by 4:00 and
Bob got here at 5:00 okay so we are
ready to go for Jack my oh my oh my god
there are so many there Oh heaven
protect me
this is seems like an unfair challenge
mark where are you I'm dying from a baby
spider
it's murdering me oh hi guys Oh Chuck
wait ran way the health or away from us
what
wait why I wear birthmark red looks I
turned back died of course he's back no
I turned back oh ha ha ha okay alright I
do not have a block anymore I was lost
so I guess I have to go deeper get
another
and so what exactly is the point what
are we doing we're trying to get blocks
from inside the mines and take them out
what are we playing blocks ketball no
we're not playing blocks Paul we got to
carry blocks one at a time okay I got
another emerald block protect me this
time I'm leading the way not you the
armed guy good uh-huh let's go scared
all right we got to get through the
zombies so you guys just gotta protect
me
can you like break um all the the cobweb
[ __ ] so we don't get stuck in them ah I
can't cuz it's best to do with a sword
okay looking good there's just a few
more and then we can plant it oh I'm
never gonna make it I'm just I'm
sprinting for it app written for it oh
I'm going I'm going I'm going
Oh God Oh God oh I'm gather I'm gonna
make it
Gallatin creeper I made it oh I'm out
where's this platform is it just this
super high got it I got a guy to do boom
11.0 yeah you guys have fun I'm running
for it again oh no really bad at this or
is this really hard this is really hard
like this we got our kids wait I'm not
supposed every out ward I'm trying man I
think we should just die our way back in
every time through fighting our way back
in just well so long as you protect that
what happened wait one of us has to stay
on the left and one of us has to stay on
the right you keep running directly in
front of me hahahahaha I swing my sword
oops way to go Wade
all right whatever just sing your song
wait and be done with it oh oh we are we
fighting somebody uh yes sucks so much
ah no I'm not so close
you bastard so cool I feel so close keep
going keep going oh my god good
I can't keep going well I got nothing
man I gotta go back can we get better
weapons hahahahahaha what the hell it
wasn't to make us get 10 blocks it was
my idea and we got plenty of time we got
we don't have a title this one I'm
keeping time we got about I don't know
16 minutes let's go away we've got one
okay we're actually working together now
you guys are in front of me hahaha
way to go Bob shut up okay so keep just
keep going and Marcus wait for me god
damn no I got it Wade's distracting him
I'm going around yeah they're eating my
flesh let's go ahead blazes blazes
where'd the blazes come from your gear
what the hell are we supposed to do I
made it out with two hell's left I made
it out oh no
oh the blazes are eating me how do you
get out I didn't know blazes good ah uh
uh okay I'm back don't look lazes is
going on shut up Wade we don't need your
puns Oh
everyone needs my phone I'm going back
in I managed I managed to pick up oh I
picked up the Emerald that I dropped
when I died before so I don't know if
that counts or not uh ich spawn should
drop better [ __ ] I'm getting raped there
needs to be better stuff I don't think
we can do about that unless you kill one
of the Pikmin they drop some diamond
gear I'm coming back out you got this
Wade uh
working on it you look like you got it
yeah you got it
it hurts me when they touch me I'll help
I will action where are you mark I'm no
model in the mines oh my god
just one is after me you just owe
dollars yes
okay I'm going God I see a gap Oh God
I'm going for it I read this come from
whistling I'm going out I'm almost I
mean let me guess uh Bob that's a zombie
I'm gonna make it ha ha ha ha ha
now come on matter picked up your
equipment I'm on fire
I'm not gonna be ok I'm good I'm good
I'm good mark come back
no I'm dropping off the Emerald I'm
gonna dot no not for we got this floor
good if you're going without your care
of it
oh my god I can't even hit him the
caravan failed me so I don't know how
I'm supposed to trust you guys again I'm
not late for us okay all right
I bet die and now am I going to the mine
and I'm gonna wait for you
hey these spiders are just ignoring me
yeah they're going for me ah painful
okay all right I'm around in a circle
wait and I'll kill them all right okay
I'm in a spider webs oh that's bad I'm
gonna I'm gonna win it
I'm good I'm gonna wait for you at the
beginning of the place and I'll wait for
my Caravan that was the whole idea of it
before I think I'm dragging them all in
here so all you're bringing like a ton
of the spot okay Bob protect me all
right ready to go okay let's do it
I am I feel so safe in your capable
hands
I'm or the right Bob you guys all right
I call that Oh
all right word I didn't get them all egg
rode on us and then mark and just like
hang out and watch for a note ha ha ha
ha the blazes wait a minute I thought I
saw something it looked like a guy in a
plaid shirt just flew through the sky no
it's more Taylor Marc run please God ha
ha ha ha run away run away Oh God ok ha
ha ha Israel blazes everything's on fire
I'm on fire
I'm so cons on Rick uh-huh there's a
baby spider out here actually I got you
five ah
all right five and we got you for us we
got nah 11:30 I don't know 11 minutes
yeah 11 minutes something like that I
don't really know I'm not keeping really
good track of time I think we should use
the creepers to make holes to trap all
these [ __ ] out here okay well there's
still creeper spawning her to desktop
I'm Ono I have no idea I'm going back in
there's not many zombies now oh yeah I'm
sure that'll last
hahahahaha I pour my concoction yeah oh
okay ah wait watch out I'm blah blah
blah I was drunken drinking drunken oh
good there's a whole [ __ ] load of stupid
spider web [ __ ] man these guys are
spawning a bunch of spider webs that's
annoying I got another one are you ready
for the caravan - a scourge let's go
look screwed won't left ok what's the
word uh it's an excursion or is a
Excalibur alright shut up wait you're an
idiot well it what's the word if it's an
excursion think bird is the word
oh my god do not start with me like I
said I just been watching family guy so
that thoroughly is annoying by now but
the bird bird bird is word above a bar
bar bar bar toad or I'm a bummer hey
it's like completely clear I'm right I'm
right here I'm sure nothing horrible is
about to befall 6 we got 6 good yeah yay
yay dying in real life because of this
I'm making it oh my
ah trapped in aloha spires
their barn on the friggin walls I'd lie
Oh dad I died I died oh this is a gear
everywhere got this butter wet ok I'm
going back for another removed we only
need four more to meet the minimum and
then if we go five more after that we'll
get a special bonus prize I must look at
the floor
why aspire way up dude hmm
I'm in a spider web mm why are you going
a boat ha ha got stuck in the floor
you're in a boat I can't get out of it
I'm just stuck in the floor on mice and
I gotta got there we go you're out go
for it man protect me and my valuable
niblets we're getting pushed back ha ha
ha oh I was getting pushed back because
Wade was just ha ha ha try to go to the
right Wade you're such dick look at Bob
back there I'm gonna try to help him I
got your back I literally cannot click
any faster than this house all right
Wade's a dick but we did it Bob
oh ha ha oh oh my god
I'm going around him Oh what happened
got like 9 spiders ha ha ha ha ha ha I'm
gonna make it
it's final hydros with terrible eyes I
made it I made it
awesome a [ __ ] we have 7 summon aah
you guys okay in there sounds like
you're dying yeah you gonna be all right
hey stop it oh ha favorite over here oh
I do
finally
but better data better turn up on a dog
check it out my robe what song is that
go thank you I'm out I didn't take a hit
of damage that entire time you guys did
great
huh let's hold this doorway wait all
right
I really hope that like monsters don't
start spawning back here where the
emeralds are yeah they're ones that
would suck really oh man that would just
be the worst whirl wind volume Livia
Livia saw me they're everywhere oh okay
Caravan away all right mark thank you
all for actually sticking by me I'm
trying place I got it these aren't that
bad I'm going I'm going I'm going I'm
going
oh ho just need three whoa my god it's
all on fire everything burned zombies
stop oh I'm gonna make it I feel a gap
I'm going for it yeah there's a million
of them I'm coming
Oh I'll pull them you run around you go
I am going around a majora that pile
just exploded into 19 zombies but I made
it we got eight nine I don't know there
are so many zombies out here oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
does you did not want to go out there
I'm out here oh you're out there okay
that's it pretty bad isn't it Bob I'm
gonna die
just clear mom and we'll get too much
gonna try and run around and hahaha I've
somehow made it oh there you are waited
such thing it's running around if
they're spawning
oh I still have my pick that's right I'm
still good
although this is ami coming up to you
mark oh no there's a place out here
let's let's lay this down here I come
magically there are now monsters down
here what's the deal
we got five minutes oh my god it's all
I'm going to get what I'm sure up it's
all made of wood
oh yeah everything here is made of wood
oh no it's always on fire put it out use
the boat use that once use the boat you
know boats run I don't know put it out
what are ya whatever haha boats it's I
don't know water pokemon oh my god oh
I'm being hit by some oh my god because
you're rolling through without us
I'm trying to make it and win this for
us you guys shut up we got like five
minutes to get to more Oh are there
still a bajillion zombies out here um oh
my god nope we're good I'm getting it
full inside of the mine is now on fire
we got nine we just need one more
oh one more I think we should go to a
different part of the line I think that
part is done what happened is it all
burned down she just burned it down
hahahaha we go in here to this place it
says mine five where where I'm being
merged sorry oh I died yeah it's gone
here can we go in here can I cut this
outfit for you or something where this
walled off area nobody over here over
here uh-huh
that's this can we go in there oh no are
there emeralds in there I don't know but
don't think so I mean besides some in
the in the ground but let me see the
devastation that happened over here
first
not one [ __ ] I think I can I think I can
make it though I think I can get it I
think I can get a caravan what we have a
caravan oh I'm on fire
but I'm making it I'm gonna make it
alright I got I got it I got it I got it
I got it I got it I got it I'm on fire
but I got it
I'm Adam
ah I fell I don't know how I fell but I
fell I'm dead oh I've got a pass mark
I've got a pat okay just do it just give
me the path I think I'm the fire like
taking damage to get here it's pretty I
I went out we got two minutes there now
right here down here where they catch
fire there where go right straight
across here and jump over just don't go
to the left or to the right I got it we
got we got literally two minutes right
now to get this out you ready ready it's
two minutes we got two minutes let's go
I got alright ball I'm gonna be covers
all right again okay mark slow down slow
okay okay okay
nice and calm we got plenty of time make
it all the way in front of you okay all
right it seems so quiet
I'm staying here I'm staying behind hey
mine I'll try to hell up I got up mark
let him pull them all from the left okay
love love your turn you're covered I got
this butters oh you I just go should I
go out no chance on me on away there's a
boss zombie it's big
Oh gigantic no think I'm gonna make it
oh he did was touch me accidentally I
better I gotta I'm sprinting for the
emeralds again oh my god
oh we're gonna make it we got to make it
we got one less than a minute left or
maybe we got more time out not exactly
sure I don't know where the time started
and we're dead we were supposed to have
20 minutes but I started the clock when
we started recording and not when we
started wrong I think we have more time
than I think we do just just are you at
the Emerald yet yes I got the Emerald
I'm going alright keep going
I'm gonna pull the boss and then okay I
see I see a path I got a path I got a
path go go go go okay I got a dig around
I just stuck that block get away from me
slime there's another giant one this is
not fair wait mark I'm not gonna make it
you destroy blocks yeah
can you mine your way out I made a gap I
made a gap I did mine my way out
actually oh you found a hole uh-uh-uh 5
seconds ha ha ha do one bam got it yeah
good yes ha ha fully I could get out and
see myself
ha ha ha
that was 10 right that's 10 kaanum yeah
I got him but under here ha ha oh my god
that is a lot of zombies holy balls
we did it ha ha ha I want a zombie ha
forward us outside oh good they they're
all gone oh hey look an emerald sitting
on the ground here oh all right 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 that's all of them
good job everybody or something all
right
so congratulations I was the first
cooperative game we ever had so thank
you Bob and Wade for helping me to
commit your sour ha ha ha ha not that
game but ok as is with all these games
just because we did it doesn't mean that
we're the winner zombie pass your
judgement upon us did we cheat did we do
it correctly
did we valiantly struggle against the
odds you think you all put you wrong I
don't think that combined correctly I
don't even think people who know that ha
ha ha ha you think you all but you levy
oh sure you think you live in your house
but you never you strong Oh
one gold star for Bob yeah Bob actually
did the heroic work wait I don't know
what you were doing but it was an entire
horde it was not it was not helping oh I
want to let them eat you
thank you yes please wait the trick is
to look like you're doing a lot and then
just die be really vocal about it - wait
you're so quiet I thought you were just
conspiring against but or the war you
scream the better let's go back so I do
it that's how drunk man craft works in
general
Oh drunk
wait zombie did that mean Bob won or was
that just a gold star
oh okay I had no idea okay well I won
that but yeah I guess ours equals win
hooray Bob hey so congratulations Bob
you won huzzah you get to be honored in
the next game whatever the hell it is
awesome Hosanna levy huzzah hahahahaha
stop it Bob stop bill stop it yeah
alright so I guess that's it I think we
went a little shorter than we usually do
but that's okay we keep it to a game per
episode so thank you all so much for
watching if you want to see this
particular game again we probably will
play it because this map is really cool
and we like it we could always do
another emerald run with another person
as the runner so if you liked it let us
know if you got an idea for another
video you let us know since Bob won he
gets to do the outro I thought we
already learned that I'm really bad at
these do it anyway thank you everybody
for watching I'm not gonna say what mark
always says that some people [ __ ] you
all know what mark always says like his
channel no that's not what you could do
to his channel or like his videos I had
our three follow me on Twitter I'm my
skirm a little bit
on their look at weights YouTube channel
he's up there he's Lord minion 777 play
some sellers of Catan and some other
stuff out there that's so why'd you go
that's you're serious and I've watched
the most of I will say so
oh but uh well yeah we'll see you guys
next time
I guess no bye bye ah bye
Oh